hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the semi-finals of
the speed chase Championship we all know
that now Magnus will face Hikaru in the
finals we also saw some of the some of
the games from the Wesley store versus
Magnus Carlsen semi-finals and now it's
time to check out what happened in
Hikaru versus Maxime we already uh have
seen the final score in the previous
video uh this is a game I decided to
show as it will also give us an idea of
what we can expect in the finals uh with
the hikawa versus Magnus well let's
check it out in this game Hikaru had the
white pieces and he opened uh with Ponte
for now leading up to this game uh in
the blitz section uh Maxim started the
match by winning three games in a row so
that was a pretty bad start for Hikaru
then one game ended in the draw then
Hikaru managed to win game five and this
is now game six so let's check it out
and uh to E4 of course you guys already
know what Maxine plays even without me
showing it to you of course spawn the C5
Maxim always goes for the Sicilian
Defense and even though you know that
it's still very hard to play against him
Knight to F3 we have these 6 Bishop to
B5 chair going for the canal attack and
the bishop to D7 he covered trades
characters captures and pawn to D3 so a
very principled idea trades of the light
Square Bishops and now puts his pawns on
light squares and he will have a dark
Square Bishop to go in between those
light squares it's all Knight the C6 by
Maxine castles and Ponte E6 now and here
a lot of moves have been played like a
rook D1 Bishop D3 some also other let's
play moves but C3 has never been played
and it is now as of move 7 that we have
a completely new game and the move of
course does a lot it prevents the knight
from coming to B4 or D4 it sets up the
future Pawn to D4 Advanced Advance
advancement it frees up this diagonal
for the queen to enter the game as of
course Hikaru is accepting expecting
Maxim to castle queenside since he still
has to develop quite a lot to actually
Castle King's side so Pawn to D5 if
white allows it of course every Sicilian
player will play this as soon as
possible Queen to E2 nice aligning the
queen with the black king and here he
caught uh MPL castles uh Knight beta D2
now the downside of having the pawn and
C3 is that you cannot put the Knight on
its natural Square which is the C3
Square so of course Knight to D2 and now
the Knight is coming to C4 or B3 not C4
right away obviously there's a Pawn on
D5 but you know maybe in the future so
Bishop to D6 maximum continues
development and now Pawn to A3 Hikaru
prepares White's strongest move and that
is Pawn to B4 we have Knight gt7 now
Maxim also ready to start advancing
those pawns on the king side and pawn to
B4 by hikar with Knight to G6 and now
Pawn to G3 fighting against the bishop
on D6 and also controlling the at the
square of um uh squares of the Knight on
G6 that the Knight can go to pawn to F5
Maxim also wants to open up the f file
to put his Rooks on DF file and now B
captures and C5 now Hikaru gets the
semi-open B file which he will use for
his uh Rooks with Bishop characters and
now Pawn to E5 you would you would like
to play D4 but then F captures an E4 and
now white is in trouble so Hikaru first
plays E5 he prevents the capture on e4
and now he will advance the pawn to D4
uh when the position calls for it we
have Pawn to F4 Maxim wants to start the
attack on the king side before Hikaru
starts the attack on the queen side but
now Knight B3 a free tempo as the bishop
on C5 is undefended the bishop to B6 and
here comes Pawn to A4 now any other move
uh uh besides the Ponte A4 will allow
Maxim to start his attack so A4 is
crucial here preparing Pawn to A5 and
there's really no good way to treat this
there is one but Maxim didn't play it
like to give an example if you play F
characters and G3 it doesn't really do
all that much like H captors now uh
still okay you could maybe go after the
E5 Pawn Let's Play Bishop C7 uh Knight
to C5 and already uh black is lost the
queen is hanging you will move the queen
D4 defends the Knight Bishop to G5 is
coming coming next and if you stop
Bishop to G5 then already Knight
captures and B7 is winning King captures
Queen comes the B5 with check now if the
king moves you will pick up the Knight
and the blacks black kings defenses have
been shattered or if you block with the
bishop then Ponte 5 will again uh win
back material because if Knight captures
then you have real captures the bishop
is pinned and so on so after A4 Queen
the F7 was played it's not a move that
helps Maxim the only move that helps
Maximus Knight to A5 but it's still not
going to be an easy game for example
captures captures Bishop A3 and the
hikaru's position is just much better
but after Queen to F7 uh Hikaru is
basically winning he plays Pawn to A5
Bishop to C7 and now Pawn to D4 stopping
all of Maxim's Contra play and Maxine
played a queen to F5 now
but it doesn't really help I thought
about making this pause the video moment
or maybe a few moves later so I decided
to use both of them yes they are very
nice so feel free to pause the video and
try to find pretty much the only
straight up winning move for Hikaru
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
beautiful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
the C5 that's the move not Ponte A6 then
like B6 and there's nothing really
happening here it is Knight the C5 which
is not easy to make uh because you uh
leave the A5 Pawn defenseless here but
it is the weight of Victory because the
B7 Pawn is the real Target so after
Bishop captures an A5 or Knight captures
doesn't really matter uh hikaru's idea
is the same Queen B5 threatens Checkmate
on B7 and after Bishop to B6 uh well you
of course know what the move is that
Hikaru prepared by playing Knight to C5
feel free to pause the video for the
second time and win the game while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on a completely
disregarding All Blacks uh the defensive
moves and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook captures an
A7 this is what Hikaru played and it was
in this position on move 21 that uh
Maxima shell Agra resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
of course if the bishop captures then
Queen captures on B7 is made in one and
if you capture with the Knight it's not
much better Queen captures some B6 again
threatens Checkmate so you can play
something like Queen to F7 to block
Checkmate as the Knight covers the D7
square but now Knight G5 attacks the
queen also the E6 spawn is now attacked
three times if you play Queen to C7 then
you win back material and now you have a
bishop a knight and the bishop for a
rook which is winning in itself already
or also your upper pawn and also there
is no way of stopping Knight captures on
E6 so here whatever you play the the
position just
collapses completely there's not even I
know you guys liked it when I finish the
games but there's just and there's not
even a move I can suggest here for black
as the position is really that bad so of
course Maxim saw this after Rook
captures on A7 he resigned and that's
pretty much it uh Hikaru although he
started the the match poorly he started
by losing the first three games he uh
got back really quickly and I won the
match convincingly so we've seen what
happened in the uh Wesley so versus
Magnus match uh Magnus won with a score
of 22-7 uh for those who haven't seen
the previous video in the five plus one
section Magnus one with a six and a half
to two and a half then in three plus one
Magnus one with eight to one uh and uh
in bullet Magnus one with seven and a
half to three and a half whereas Hikaru
against Maxine uh Hikaru won the blitz
section although like I said he started
with a down three points he won it with
five five to four then he lost the three
plus one section with a score of three
and a half to five and a half but then
he completely made up for it in bullet
as he won the bullet section with eight
to two uh so the final score was 16 and
a half to 11 and a half so not quite the
difference the Magnus managed to do
against Wesley so so we'll see how
Hikaru does in the finals he says he
will have to do a lot better than he did
here when he was playing with scene but
he if he brings his A-game he definitely
has a chance and as I understand that
the Magnus is still leading uh in their
um uh final matches of the speeches
Championship ships that they've met uh
three times already and Magnus uh has a
two to one advantage so if your car wins
now he equalizes and they have an equal
score if Magnus wins uh he gets a three
to one advantage and as Magnus said uh
the winner will definitely have a
bragging uh rights for the for for the
foreseeable future or maybe Hikaru said
that I have no idea uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
much looking forward to the final match
I would like to thank Alan Saul
hartstein uh Paul Miller Kenneth Fraser
Ludy and Ralph and Nick met in Yasser
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check
out my you want for suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day